اصدر رجلا الدين الشيعيين البارزان في
لبنان السيد هاني فحص والسيد محمد حسن
الامين اصد بيانا اكد فيه وقوفهما مع ثوره
الشعب
السوري
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين الهدف من البيان ومغزى صدوره في
هذا التوقيت وتاثير البيان على الثوره
السوريه سلبا او
ايجابا السلام عليكم وتقبل الله
صومكم ليست هذه المره الاولى التي يتخذ
فيها السيدان هاني فحس ومحمد الامين مواقف
ف متباينه عن تلك التي يتخذها حزب الله في
لبنان ومن ورائه غالبيه الشيعه المهم هذه
المره ان الاختلاف يرتبط بموضوع بموضوع له
تاثيراته الكبيره على الساحه اللبنانيه هو
موضوع الثوره السوريه فبيان التاييد
للثوره الصادر عن العالمين هو الاول من
نوعه كما انه استخدم لهجه قويه وصلت الى
حد الحديث عن الاحتلالات الوطنيه التي
استخدمت فلسطين والعروبه والممانعه ضد
شعوب
الله اكبر نحو 17 شهرا والثوره السوريه ما
فتئت تلقي بظلالها وانعكاساتها على مختلف
الصعود المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه ولم
يكن لبنان والشيعه هناك استثناء وظل تاييد
حزب الله لنظام الرئيس بشار الاسد واضحا
في مختلف المنابر ولكن القياديين الشيعيين
اللبنانيين البارزين هاني فحص عضو المجلس
الاسلامي الشيعي الاعلى والقاضي محمد حسن
الامين اصدر بيانا اكد فيه وقوفهما مع
الثوره السوريه قال بيان القياديين انهما
يناصر الثوره السوريه كما ناصر الثورات
الفلسطينيه والايرانيه والليبيه وباقي
الحركات المطالبه بالاصلاح في كل الدول
العربيه وان موقفهما ينسجم مع مكوناتهما
العربيه والاسلاميه وخصوصيته الشيعيه وروح
الاسلام الوحدويه وقال حان فحص الجزيره نت
ان النظام السوري يسعى لاشعال فتنه طائفيه
و ناشد الثوار منع النظام من تحقيق احلامه
يختلف اذا موقف المرجعين الشيعيين تماما
مع موقف حزب الله اكبر تنظيمات الشيعه في
لبنان المؤيد للنظام السوري منذ اندلاع
الثوره عليه ويختلف موقفهما كذلك مع ايران
وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي يظهر فيها
ذلك اثار ما تحدث عنه المرجعيين الشيعيين
في بيانهما عن انعكاس استقرار سوريا على
لبنان واضحه على الساحه اللبنانيه وما
تدفق اعداد اللاجئين الكبيره الى لبنان
سوى واحده من الامور الواضحه للعيان وليس
ببعيد عن الاذهان اشتباكات منطقتي درب
التبانه وجبل محسن بطرابلس عاصمه الشمال
اللبناني التي جرت في مايو الماضي بين
مؤيدي الثوره السوريه ومؤيدي النظام وادت
لانتشار الجيش في شارع سوريا الفاصل بين
الجانبين وطغت المخاوف حينها ولا تزال من
انتقال انعكاسات الاحداث في سوريا الى ان
اخرى في لبنان رؤيه المرجعين الشيعيين ان
استقرار لبنان يكمن في قيام سوريا مستقره
وحره وديمقراطيه تتفق مع رؤى كثيره محليا
واقليميا ودوليا ولكنها تشكل مع غيرها من
بنود البيان ابرز المواقف الشيعيه التي لا
تعارض فقط النظام السوري انما تختلف ايضا
حتى مع مؤيديه الشيعه في لبنان
وغيرها معنا في هذه الحلقه من الشوف في
جبل لبنان السيد هاني فحص عضو الهيئه
الشرعيه في المجلس الاسلامي الشيعي الاعلى
في لبنان ومن بيروت الدكتور عماد الحوت
النائب في البرلمان اللبناني عن الجماعه
الاسلاميه ومعنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
غسان عايش شبانا رئيس العلاقات رئيس قسم
العلاقات الدوليه في جماعه مير مونت
الامريكيه اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا سيد
هاني
فحس سيد فحس لماذا هذا البيان
هذا البيان
ل يريد ان
يقول بان
الشيعه يجب ان يكونوا منسجمين مع تراثهم
ومع
تاريخهم ومع انحيازهم دائما للعدل ضد
الجور وللحريه ضد
الاستبداد وان المشهد الشيعي
اي السائد لا يختزل
الشيعه خاصه وانه مركب ب ب بعوامل متعدده
يعني فيها نوع من الاستقواء والاستدبار
والاستلس على ايضا على على على ما كان
يتنافى تاريخيا مع توجه الشيعه وخاصه توجه
الامام موسى الصدر اخيرا والامام شمس
الدين رحمهما الله من دعوه الشيعه الى
الاندماج الاندماج يعني التفاهم مع
اقوامهم وفي واهل
اوطانهم ينبغي يعني هذا يفترض ان يتفاهموا
اكثر كما تفاهموا سابقا وتنازلوا سابقا عن
كثير من حقوقهم في سبيل الوطن ووحده الوطن
والوفاق وفي سبيل النهوض والسلام دا من
المستعمر والمحتل الى اخره ولكن ولكن اسمح
لي سيد فحص يعني لماذا ل عفوا يعني لماذا
انتظرتم كل هذه الفتره حتى تعلنوا مع ع
اولا لم ننتظر لم ننتظر من يتابعنا ويتابع
غيرنا من الشخصيات الشيعيه المستقله
والمعتدله والمتوازن يلاحظ اننا دائما كنا
نعبر عن موقف واحد بهذا الاتجاه غايه
الامر ان ان
جرعه جرعه القوه في كلامنا كانت تتناسب مع
مع مع مع اللحظه ولم نكن نحن لا نريد ان
ندخل في فتنه ن نسنع حريصين على القطيعه
مع حزب الله وحركه ام امل وايران ونح
وقلنا لهم اننا يعني نحن عقلنا وحدنا لا
يكفينا وهم عقلهم وحدهم لا يكفيهم لابد من
ان يصغوا يصغوا من موقع الاستئناف ومن
موقع الاسترشاد ومن موقع التفاهم الى كل
الاصوات الشيعيه وغير الشيعيه التي لا
تضمن لهم حقدا
ولكنها دائما جاهزه للنقد والنقد الودود
النق ه هل تطمعون نعم عفوا سيد حسن هل هل
تطمعون الى تشكيل تيار جديد شيعي ضاغط لان
البيان ندعو اهلنا الى الانسجام مع انفسهم
الى اخره في تاييد انتفاضات العربيه
والاسلاميه اولا يعني انا اريد ان اقول
انه ينبغي ان نقرا في ماضينا القريب
والبعيد هي وحده ومش انا فقط انا وسيد
محمد حسن الامين هناك حاله شيعيه في لبنان
حاله شيعيه تتسرب صورتها وصوتها بين حين
واخر وخلال ايام عندنا بيان بمستوى او
اقوى من هذا البيان الذي وقعته مع السيد
الامين و
ستوقع شخصيات وكفاءات ونخب شيعيه لها
حضورها ويمكن ان يمتد التوقيع الى الشيعه
في البلاد العربيه اي
هذه اما انه نريد ان نؤسس تيارا
ا من من من من سنوات كنا نفكر بذلك وكنا
نخاف نخاف ان ان ان هذا التيار يتحول الى
الى اضافه طائفيه للوضع في لبنان نعم نحن
الان نسعى الى ان نتشكل بشكل مرن وواقعي
ورحب غير حزبي وغير عصبي شيعيا في اطار
وطني يعني ان نضمن تشكلنا الشيعي او
خصوصيتنا الشيعيه بالاطار الوطني العام
الذي ضبطنا والذي نغني ولا ننفصل عنه اذا
اذا طالما ان هذه المبادره يمكن ان نصفها
بانها نواه لتوجه مستقبلي سيكون اوسع
لبنانيا وعربيا واسلاميا هنا نسال الدكتور
عماد الحوت يمكن ويمكن ان نعتبرها نتيجه
نتيجه مبادره حصلت فعلا نعم وكانت هذ
وكانت هذه البيانات الان احد علامات
تبلورها نعم الى اي مدى دكتور عماد الحوت
هذا التوجه نظر اليه في لبنان بشكل ايجابي
بعد فتره طويله للاسف صنف الامر وكان
الشيعه مع القمع في سوريا ضد الشعب والسنه
يقفون مع الجمهور مع مع جمهور الغاضبين
والثائرين في ليبيا عفوا في سوريا مع ان
الامر ليس بالضروره بهذه
الحديه انا باعتقادي انه هناك صوره مغلوطه
تقدم للواقع الاسلامي الشيعي في لبنان وفي
العالم العربي هناك من يريد ان يضع الاخوه
الشيعه في مواجهه كل الناس وفي مواجهه
الشعوب في المنطقه ايضا لكنني انا اعتقد
ان هناك من الاصوات الكثيره وليست قليله
كاصوات السيد هاني فحص والسيد محمد حسن
الامين وغيرهم كثر سوف تظهرهم الايام
القادمه انهم ليسوا اقليه في هذا الاطار
انما هم اصواتهم لا تصل بهذه السهوله لان
هناك من لا يريد لهذه الاصوات ان تصل
اعتقد انه مبادره السيدين السيد هاني فحص
والسيد محمد حسن الامين اوجدت شيء من
الارتياح في الشارع اللبناني لاننا فعلا
نريد ان نخرج من هذه الاصطفافات المذهبيه
الحاده التي ان استمرت بهذا الشكل ان
اتحصن بمذهب او بطائف في وجه جمهور اخر
هذا هو الذي يؤدي الى فتنه فتنه مذهبيه او
فتنه اهليه التصرف الواعي والسليم الذي
قام به السيدين هاني فحص محمد حسن الامين
هو احدى السبل الاساسيه لتجنب هذه الفتنه
نعم سيد جبانا ما اهميه ان ان يصدر مثل
هذا البيان في سياق اقليمي يحذر فيه
كثيرون من فتنه طائفيه شيعيه سنيه بهذا
التصنيف الذي ذكرته قبل قليل فيما يتعلق
بالثوره السوريه مهم جدا على الصعيد
المحلي في لبنان وعلى الصعيد الاقليمي في
سوريا وفي العراق و وفي ايران الرساله
مفادها بان هناك فكر نهضوي صحوه شيعيه
الان بدات في لبنان تقول للعالم باسره بان
الشيعه في فكرهم السياسي وفي فلسفتهم ال
الرومانسيه السياسيه ليسوا وحده واحده
وليسوا ولا ينظرون الى كل الامور بنظره
واحده هذا اولا ثانيا اعتقد بانها ترسل
رساله واضحه الى الاخوه السنه في جميع
المناطق خاصه في الاقليم الذي يعيش في
نعيش فيه في الشرق الاوسط بان يوجد هناك
علماء شيعه يرون بانه لا مجال ولا ولا
يعني لا مجال للفتنه في هذه اللحظه ما بين
الاخوين السني والشيعه قد يكون هناك خلافا
سياسيا مفا هذا المرسوم كان يق قد يكون
هناك خلافا سياسيا ولكن الخلاف ليس مذهبيا
عقائديا لذلك الرساله واضحه وتقول باننا
نقف الى جانب الشعب السوري بشتى الوانه
يعني لا اعتقد بان في سوريا الان السنه هم
من يديرون الحراك يوجد اخوه علويين يوجد
اخوه من المسيحيين يوجد اخوه من الاكراد
ويوجد اخوه من الدروز كلهم مجتمعين على
تغيير النظام كلهم مجتمعين ايضا اعتقد
يرسل رساله واضحه الى ايران بان يعني
الايرانيين في هذ هذ اللحظه جدا مشغولون
بت تصدير كل همومهم الداخليه ومشاكلهم
الداخليه الى الخارج عبر انشاء دوله امنيه
في الداخل وتطمين او او او دعم الحراك
السوري الداخلي امنيا لذلك ايران تريد شغل
المنطقه بعده مشاكل في هذه اللحظه كي لا
تنتبه كي لا ينتبه الشعب الايراني داخليا
الى المشاكل الايرانيه كذلك في العراق
اعتقد بانه ارسال مثل هذه الصوره الى
العراق يرسل ايضا رساله مفادها بان الاخوه
الشيعه في لبنان وهي المركزيه الاهم في
هذه اللحظه بالنسبه للملف السوري لقرب
لقرب الاخوه الشيعه من من سوريا في لبنان
ولدعم حزب الله الى الى الشيعه في في في
سوريا نعم سيد هاني فحص واضح من خلال
البيان التاكيد على ان ال روح التوجه
الشيعي هو في ان يقف مع المظلوم وان هذه
هي الروح الاساسيه في التوجه الشيعي برايك
الى اي مدى هذه الوقفه مع الثوره السوريه
والتنديد
باستعمال فلسطين والعروبه والممانعه غطا
لقمع تطلعات شعب نحو التغيير ونحو
الديمقراطيه الى اي مدى هذا التوجه يمكن
ان يلقى صدى شعبيا داخل داخل لبنان ليس
فقط في قيادات رمزيه وفي توقيعات تتوقعها
في في الفتره
المقبله لو كانت هذه التوقيعات او هذه
البيانات لا تمثل كتله بشريه وحامل
اجتماعي لها ما كانت صدرت لسنا مغامرين
واضافه لذلك لسنا طارئين نحن موجودون في
الحركات المطليه وفي حركات المقاومه
والحركه السياسيه والحركه الثقافيه
نحن نحن الاثنين و وغيرنا ايضا اصدقاؤنا
على المستوى الشيعي لنا لنا تاريخ فنحن
نعبر عن حاله موجوده غايه الامر ان هذه
هذه هذه
الحاله الان مكلفه بان تنمو وان تتماس وان
تظهر وان تؤثر اكثر وان يعلو صوته وان
تستقطب اكثر وهناك ايضا ظروف او او فرص
للاستقطاب والهم الاساسي همنا الاساسي نحن
ننجح اذا استطعنا ان نتفادى الفتنه وننجح
اقل اذا خرجنا بانفسنا عن مسار الفتنه
يعني برانا انفسنا منها اذا وقعت المهم
انلا تقع الفتنه وهذا يعني هذا يعني اذا
اردنا ان نتكلم
بكلام مذهبي بمعناه
الانثروبولوجي او الاجتماعي مش بمعناه
العصبي هذا معناه انه هذا الصوت الشيعي
يحتاج حتى يؤثر ويسمع و ويكبر
ويفعل الى صوت سني سوري اولا وعربي ثانيا
يعني نحن نحتاج الى الى الى الصوت المصري
مثلا الى الازهر الى الازهر والى التناغم
بين الازهر والنجف حتى نعيد الاخوه
الايرانيين الى الواقع الى العقلانيه ا
ونقول لهم بان النظام السوري لن يمكنهم من
نصرته سيسقط على رؤوسهم ورؤوسنا فلتسلم
فلنحاول ان تسلم رؤوسنا لحتى نكمل حتى
نكمل وايران دوله موجوده دوله تعيش في
سوق حضاري واقتصادي والى اخره فعلى ماذا
تراهن على ماذا تراهن ثم كيف
يعني ايران تقبل ايران الثوره الثوره التي
وقفنا معها ضد ظلم الشاه ولم يقصر الشعب
السوري في ذلك ها كيف تتجاهل
السوري هذا
ما كل على اهميه على اهميه هذا البيان سيد
هاني فحس على اهميه هذا البيان شيعيا
ولبنانيه واقليميا ربما المطروح الان ايضا
ان ننظر اليه وهذا ما سنتطرق اليه بعد
الفاصل التاثير مثل هذا البيان وهذا
التوجه
الجديد على الثوره السوريه وسيرورتها لنا
عوده الى هذه النقطه بعد فاصل قصير نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها البيان الهام
الذي
اصدره العالمان الشيعيين البارزان في
لبنان السيد هاني فحص والسيد محمد حسن
الامين وايد فيه بشكل واضح الثوره
السوريه سيد شبانا برايك اي تاثير يمكن ان
يكون لمثل هذا البيان مثل هذا التوجه الذي
شرحه السيد فحص على الثوره السوريه تاثير
كبير على يعني على الصعيد الادبي على
الصعيد الاخلاقي وايضا على الصعيد الديني
المراد الان هو بان يترجم مثل هذا القرار
او هذا البيان الى ارض الواقع بان يؤيد
علماء شيعه اكثر وعلماء سنه اكثر يعني
حينما ذكر العلامه بان على الازهر ان
يتحرك اعتقد بانه على الازهر ان يتحرك
اعتقد انه ايضا في ثورات الشعوب عاده ما
تدخل رجال الدين او الفلاسفه لانقاذ
الشعوب من انفسهم يعني في التاريخ
الاوروبي القديم او الحديث نرى بان جان
جاك روسو فولتير كالفن ماكس فيبر كل هؤلاء
الناس تدخلوا لانقاذ الشعوب من انفسها
وكتابه عهده اجتماعيه سوشال كونتراكت
لانقاذ الشعوب من انفسها وترجمه ماذا يريد
هذا الشعب وماذا يريد ذلك الشعب مثل هذا
البيان ممكن اخذه بعين الاعتبار في
اسطنبول وفي وفي القاهره وفي بلاد اخرى
لنركز على وحده واحده وهي بان الفتنه
مرفوضه الطائفيه مرفوضه كل الكلام عن حرب
اهليه او حرب طائفيه في سوريا مرفوض لانه
ذلك سوف يجهد الثوره السوريه كل الذين
يؤججون في هذه اللحظه او او كل الذين
ينظرون الى حرب اهليه في سوريا هم يقولون
كلمه واحده اجهاض الثوره السوريه لانه اذا
ما اذا ما كان الناتج للثوره للثوره
السوريه هو حرب اهليه اذا اجهدت الثوره
مثل هذا البيان اعتقد بانه يوقف مثل هذه
الادعاءات نعم دكتور عماد الحو في في
بيروت ايضا من اهم ما جاء في في البيان
بان من من ضمانات سلام المستقبل في لبنان
ان تكون سوريا مستقره وحره تحكمها دوله
ديمقراطيه تعدديه وجامعه وعصريه موقف واضح
لا لبس فيه هل تعتقد بان بيان السيد فحص
والسيد الامين ربما يعكس كفه التيار
المؤيد للثوره السوريه داخل لبنان على
الاقل في هذه المرحله على
القريبه مما لا شك فيه انه هذا
يدعم جبهه المؤيدين لثوره الشعب السوري
المح لكن ليس هذا
فحسب هذا البيان بتوقيته من الاهميه
بمكان
وجود عصبيه هناك من يشحنها في ذهن الشعب
السوري بان هناك محور قوامه النظام في
سوريا ايران وحزب الله يقاتل معا للبقاء
وكانه هناك يعني دفع باتجاه مذهبه هذه
الثوره ياتي هذا البيان ليقول انه هذا
الكلام غير صحيح وان هذه الثوره ليست ثوره
مذهب او طائفه هي ثوره شعب باكمله وجميع
من هم يعلمون الحق ويشجعون الحريه سواء
كانوا مسلمين او مسيحيين سواء كانوا سنه
او شيعه يعلنون موقفا واضحا من دعم ثوره
الشعب السوري وبالتالي يجنب الثوره
السوريه كاس الفتنه المذهبيه والحرب
الاهليه وهذا ايضا له انعكاس ايجابي على
لبنان في ظل هذا الشحن المتزايد مذهبيا
والذي ينبغي ان نتعاون جميعا على احتوائه
ومنع انتشاره بشكل اكبر اذا اخذنا في
الاعتبار ما قاله السيد فحص قبل قليل من
ان التوجه القريب هو المزيد من التوقيعات
هل تعتقد بان هذا ايضا سيدفع اكثر في
الاتجاه الذي اشرت اليه
الان بما لا شك فيه وجود راي حر عاقل هو
كان موجود دائما كامثال السيد هاني فحص
والسيد الامين لكن صوته كان ممنوع ان يعلو
بشكل المناسب او ان يسمع بشكل المناسب
وجود تيار من هذا النوع لدى الطائفه
الشيعيه الكريمه اخواننا الشيعه سيؤدي الى
الى ان يتحول الباقي الى صيغه العقل من
جديد وان يفكروا بالعقل اولا وبضوابط
الاسلاميه الواضحه والمستقر ثانيا من اجمل
ما كتب في هذا البيان انه وضع قاعده
اسلاميه واضحه ان نكون مع المظلوم كائنا
من كان واينما كان ف وبالتالي وجود هكذا
تيار عقلي منصف يقول الحق سيدفع الاخرين
الى التفكير والى العوده الى هذا النمط من
التفكير ومن هذا النمط من الموقف وبالتالي
نرجع الى حاله وسطيه تستطيع ان تاتل
وتتكامل
وتندمج مع مع واقعها كما قال السيد هاني
فحص في بدايه كلامه نعم سيد هاني فحص ما
التاثير الذي
تامون سوريا من مثل هذا
البيان نريد ان نتفادى
الفتنه الطائفيه التي يريدها النظام حتى
يقول بانه انا او
الطوفان نحن نريد لا نريد طوفان
ونريد يعني دا في تاريخ الثورات هناك فوضى
هناك متسلقون نريد ان هذه الظاهره ينتبه
اليها من دون مبالغه لا نبالغ في الامر
نريد لسوريا ان تكون تجربه متقدمه جدا من
خلال الثوره في حمايه
التعدد على نصاب الوحده الوطنيه
السوريه
نريد في سوريا دوله متقدمه دوله نستفيد
منها وبتست فيد منها فلسطين وبستفيد منها
كل احرار العرب والمسلمين ف البيان يريد
ان يقول
للسوريين هذا صوت شيعي هذا صوت شيعي
لتقليل الاخطاء التي ترتكب من قبلكم او
باسمكم نريد ان
نتعاون نريد ان ننشئ ونؤسس
حاله حاله من حكماء الشيعه والسنه وبقيه
الطوائف في في سوريا من اجل ان تسلم
الثوره وتقل خسائرها شكرا جزيلا لك
العلامه السيد هاني فحس عضو الهيئه
الشرعيه في المجلس الاسلامي الشيعي الاعلى
كنت معنا من لبنان شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
بيروت الدكتور عماد الحوت النائب في
البرلمان اللبناني عن الجماعه الاسلاميه
وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو دكتور
غسان عايش بان رئيس قسم العلاقات الدوليه
في جماعه مير مونت الامريكيه بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء